the spiderverse is bigger than ever
before in the oscar-winning movies first
sequel if you thought into the
spider-verse was dense with Easter eggs
hold on to your web shooters You Ain't
Seen Nothing Yet warning spoilers ahead
for Spider-Man across the spiderverse
though into the spider-verse functions
as a cohesive narrative across the
spider versus a first part of a
completed story with beyond the spider
verse said to pick up where it leaves
off however across the spider-verse
continues to use a lot of the film
language the original established one of
those motifs is the use of comic book
covers to establish new characters as
well as catch up with older ones alright
people let's do this one last time
opens with narration from Gwen Stacy of
Earth 65 examining her backstory of
Spider Woman and teasing her betrayal of
Miles later on many of those who watched
into the spider-verse will recognize the
similarities between this opening
sequence and the introduction of Chris
Pine's Peter Parker in the first film
some fans May notice that Stacy's comic
book cover drops on top of the existing
covers that were Shonen into the
spider-verse the trend also continues
for the reintroduction of Miles as well
as the introduction of new characters
furthermore some of these comic book
covers are loot to the character's
narrative history for Miles first proper
meeting with Miguel O'Hara otherwise
known as Spider-Man 2099 a comic book
cover that flashes on screen directly
references the first issue of Spider-Man
Miles Morales remains a protagonists of
across the spider-verse while the
extended opening of the film centers a
narrative on Gwen Stacy following the
events of into the spider-verse when
she's not slinging webs and avoiding
captivity Gwen also shreds on the drum
kit which serves as the opening image of
the film after she's finally interrupted
midsolo comic book fans would notice a
bass drum which is labeled the Mary
Janes obviously this fictional band name
is a direct reference to Mary Jane
Watson who is Peter Parker's other
notable love interest however Gwen's
involvement in the Mary Jane's dates
back to her comic book Origins the band
made their debut in spider Gwen's
introductory comic edge of spider-verse
released in 2014. in that comic her
fellow band members are established as
Betty Brandt a version of Mary Jane
Watson who later becomes Carnage and
Gloria Grant
over the years many actors have taken on
characters in the Spider-Man franchise
but arguably only one performer has
redefined an iconic antagonist of Peter
Parker that's actors none other than JK
Simmons who will forever be remembered
as Jay Jonah Jameson of The Daily Bugle
crap crap Mega crap
I'll give you 200 bucks for all of them
after appearing in some Remy's original
trilogy fans of Spider-Man were thrilled
to see Simmons for prices role in the
mid-credits team for Spider-Man far from
home Simmons and played a small role as
Peter Parker's loudest critic in the
follow-up no way home and makes a
comeback via voice over and across the
spider-verse protesting the actions of
spider people throughout the Multiverse
the character even briefly appears in
the flesh or rather brick or during one
sequence that takes place in the world
of Lego Spider-Man which is the only
time in the film Peter Parker's work at
The Daily Bugle is referenced
Gwen Stacy's backstory is only briefly
alluded to and into the spider-verse as
her character introduction explains how
her best friend Peter Parker became the
lizard and was subsequently defeated by
Gwen and battle however the opening of
across the spiderverse delves deeper
into the characters and what led to this
moment which all originates in Gwen
Stacy's introduction to spider-gwen in
Marvel Comics after getting bitten by a
radioactive spider Gwen begins living a
double life for Spider Woman using her
powers of super strength to intimidate
Peter Parker's bullies on the side
however fed up with being picked on
Parker Downs the lizard's serum turning
himself into a monster that a tuxed
school prom as an active revenge against
his bullies Gwen unknowingly kills peace
from the subsequent fight and runs away
when her father Captain Stacy shows up
at the scene of the crime to find Spider
Woman standing over a murdered Peter
Parker although this is established and
into the spider-verse as Gwen's
reasoning for remaining distant from
others his explanation in the cross of
spider-verse follows the art from a
debut comic some of the sequences in
this extended opening even mirror from
the comic such as one moment when Peter
injects himself with Dr Connor serum
Peter's final worse a spider Gwen joined
this scene are also directly taken from
the comic revealing he knew her secret
identity
the world of the MCU has been focused on
the concept of the Multiverse Lately
from the bureaucracy policing the flow
of time in Loki to the introduction of
the next Avengers level threat in the
multiversal Conqueror Kang however into
the spider-verse was the first Marvel
film to really delve into the comic book
origins of the Multiverse the Multiverse
also played a major role in another
Spider-Man film Spider-Man no way home
in which Tom Holland's Peter Parker
becomes a target of super villains from
the Sony verse after convincing Doctor
Strange to toy with the memories of
everyone on Earth but these events seem
to be obliquely referenced that across
the spiderverse by Miguel O'Hara during
an early scene in the film as he
describes the instability of the
Multiverse
1999-99
[Music]
Genki Lee in Marvel Comics as Miles
Morales his best friend as well as one
of the few people who knows her secret
identity however the character's
appearance and into the spider-verse was
a minor non-speaking role see most
notably when he walks Cinema miles on
the other spider people hiding in their
shared dorm room however Genki makes a
slightly more prominent appearance than
across the spider verse and Miles stops
in his dorm after capturing the spot and
asks Genki to call the cops during the
brief moment between miles and Genki
Genki expresses disinterest in being
miles guy in the chair which results in
him not doing anything when the spot
eventually escapes captivity for fans of
the Tom Holland Spider-Man movies the
phrase a guy in the chair will sound a
little familiar as it said many times by
Peter Parker's friend Ned Leeds he I'll
be your guy in the chair what
you are this guy
with the headset telling the other guy
where to go this Easter egg also
references some connective tissue
between Genki Lee and the mcu's Ned
Leeds the latter looks visually much
closer to gankili in the comics than he
does to Ned leaves and eventually
becomes a Hobgoblin
Phil Lord and Christopher Miller have a
long history of producing and creating
animated films including Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs and the Mitchells
versus the machines the two also
co-produced into the spider-verse and
returned to help pen the scripts for
both across the spider-verse and 2024's
Beyond the spider-verse given their
greater creative input on the second and
third films of the trilogy Lord and
Miller saw an opportunity to pay
tributes one of their biggest successes
in animation that success is The Lego
Movie which the creative Duo co-wrote
and co-directed was released in 2014 to
glowing reviews for its stop-motion
style animation and storytelling the two
also co-wrote and producer films 2019
sequel The Lego Movie 2 the second part
as well as producing the Lego Batman
movie The Lego Ninjago movie and
spin-off Cartoon Network series Unikitty
in across the spiderverse Lord and
Miller go back to their Lego roots for a
moment in the film when the spots while
jumping between multiverses ends up
creating havoc in the Animated World of
Lego Spider-Man slipping away from his
job at The Daily Bugle Lego Spider-Man
himself contacts Miguel O'Hara and the
Spidey Society to alert them to the
danger of the spot setting off many of
the events of the film though it's the
moment most he played for Laughs as a
funny Easter egg for Lord and Miller's
past work
Lord and Miller's work isn't the only
thing referenced to join the Spas
Multiverse jumping in across the
spider-verse when the spot crashes into
the Lego Spider-Man world he also
mistakenly ends up in a live-action Sony
verse where he has a brief interaction
with Mrs Chen played by Peggy Liu the
owner of a convenience store that Tom
Hardy's Eddie Brock frequents in venom
and its sequel Venom Let There Be
Carnage hilariously Mrs Shen is in
phased by the presence of the Spas which
may have something to do with the fact
that she is briefly a symbiot host and
let there be Carnage
while hanging out at night with his
uncle Aaron miles is like many spider
people across the Multiverse bitten by a
radioactive spider however what makes
miles an anomaly is that his spider came
to his home world of Earth 1610 from a
different Universe Earth 42 with Miles
acquisition of powers resulting in the
death of his universe as Peter Parker
and the instability of the Multiverse
though the this fact plays an important
role in why Miguel O'Hara Target Smiles
as well as why miles himself ends up on
Earth 42 at the end of the film the
number on that spider is no coincidence
Miles Morales co-creator Brian Michael
Bendis numbered the radioactive spider
as a nun to the legendary baseball
player Jackie Robinson who wore the
number 42. a number pops up in a number
of places throughout into the
spider-verse and miles can be seen
wearing a jersey with the number 42 in
across the spider-verse the number 42
also holds additional meaning for sci-fi
fans in The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy 42 is established as the answer
to as the book States the ultimate
question of life the universe and
everything yeah
when Miguel thinks a mild status as a
universe sending anomaly is a problem
maybe it means that he's the answer
instead
in the history of Spider-Man as a film
franchise there is probably no scene as
iconic as a big romantic moment in some
Remy's 2002 film you know the one after
rescuing Kirsten Dunst Mary Jane Watson
from a group of muggers in the rain an
upside down Toby Maguire passionately
kisses his high school Crush while few
romantic pairings have been able to hold
a candle to Maguire and Dunstan
Spider-Man Miles and Gwen's flirtations
and across the spider-verse come pretty
close before Gwen disappears into a
portal to chase down the spot she turns
around and knowingly face to face with
an upside down invisible miles though
they don't end up locking lips it's
still a niso marsh one of the most
iconic scenes in Spider-Man history and
sets up their romantic tension to
continue in the next film
Aunt May isn't as present and across the
spider verse as she was and into the
spider-verse with Miles establishing
early in the film that she moved to
Florida though this seems like a random
fact it actually has some basis in Aunt
May's comic book Origins the answer made
out of beers and the Miles Morales
Comics has family that lives in Florida
making her move there and across the
spider-verse potentially a homecoming
for her of course Florida is also a
popular state for elderly citizens to
retire in so maybe we're reading too
much into our May's choice of new
destination still in the tangled web of
the spider-verse films no details go
unnoticed so it's possible that Aunt May
has a road Adventure ahead of her when
she arrives in the Sunshine State
into the spider-verse was heralded as an
outstanding tribute to the history of
Marvel Comics not the different
characters of the films and body
differing comic book Aesthetics but the
film's narrative also cleverly utilizes
comic book tropes to enhance the
storytelling one example of this is
through its use of comic book flourishes
to make the film feel like a comic book
page brought to life and across the
spider verse there are many moments that
utilize editor's notes which briefly
flash on screen too as they do in comics
provide context for the audience on
characters cultural differences and
unexplained lore however one editor's
note an across the spider verse makes a
callback to her beloved character from
into the spider-verse spider-ham during
the confrontation between the
Renaissance vulture and Gwen Stacy
Miguel O'Hara and Jessica Drew her
Harvard comments on vulture's use of
hammer space according to an editor's
note Hammer space refers to a cartoon
character's ability to pull objects such
as a large hammer out of their pocket
seemingly from thin air obviously those
who have seen into the spider-verse
recognize this as an ability possessed
by spider-ham he gradually does pull a
comically large hammer out of his pocket
during one of the film's climatic scenes
in 2018 two major spider events happened
Spider-Man into the spider-verse hit
theaters and insomnia games release
Spider-Man for the PlayStation 4. since
then Insomniac has developed several
expansions and C course including 2020's
Spider-Man Miles Morales which retails
the origin story of the spider-verse
protagonist and his partnership with
Peter Parker naturally the Insomniac
gains iterations of Spider-Man make
multiple appearances and across the
spider-verse at first miles roommate
Genki Lee can be seen playing Spider-Man
on his TV instead of writing an essay
drawing several early scenes in the film
however the more prominent Cameo comes
way later in the film when miles was
being taken to meet Spider-Man 2099 in
the spider society's headquarters at one
point the Insomniac Spiderman as well as
insomniac's Miles Morales appear among
the residents of Nueva York in a full
CGI render just like in the games
the climax of across the spider-verse
comes and Miles Morales has taken to
Nueva York on Earth 928 and Miguel
O'Hara has gathered the spider Society
the sequence where Miles Morales has
introduced to this Society is filled
with more cameos and one audience member
will be able to spot in one sitting
predictably most of these alternate
spider people originate from comic books
or other official Marvel produced
Spider-Man content among some of the
highlights are Otto Octavius says
superior Spider-Man while Alfred Molina
cameos has duck Arc through archival use
of his voice from no way home other
spider people that appear include spider
doppelganger iron spider Julia
Carpenter's Spider-Woman Peter parked
car ultimate tarantula and Spider-Man
2211.
do I have web on my face with steel one
of the most surprising cameos and across
the spider verse has been a long time in
the making at one point during miles
exploration of the spider society's
headquarters it meets an alternate
version of his uncle Aaron Davis aka the
prowler but this version of Aaron Davis
has played by a live-action Donald
Glover who originally debuted the
character in the mcu's Spider-Man
homecoming that's a low-level criminal
when Tom Holland's Peter Parker
interrogates for information about the
vulture what might make fans extra
excited is that at this time Glover's
actually wearing the costume although a
deleted post-credits scene in homecoming
tease Glover's Aaron Davis's close
relationship with Miles Morales the
character has yet to reappear in the
film franchise yeah sorry miles I'm not
going to make it yeah I'm just stuck
while the appearance of Glover is enough
to satisfy many fans it also serves as
an Easter egg to the origin of Miles
Morales as a character according to
Comic Book Creator Brian Michael Bendis
miles design was inspired by Glover he
was the subject of an online fan
campaign to get him cast as Peter Parker
in The Amazing Spider-Man man it won't
be the last time you'll see Glover in a
Spider-Man related film either the
Atlanta Creator is also set to star in a
future Sony vs film as a minor comic
book character Hypno Hustler a frequent
antagonist of Spider-Man
the Multiverse has played a major role
in the on-screen Marvel Universe lately
largely thanks to Spider-Man into the
spider-verse in the Years following the
end of the infinity Saga and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Marvel characters are
begun exploring the Multiverse beginning
with the 2021 Disney plus series Loki
which centers on the god of Mischief
being recruited by the mysterious time
variance Authority whose goal is to
maintain the sanctity of the Sacred
timeline in the first season finale of
Loki Loki and his female variant Sylvie
bear witness to the sacred timeline
beginning to split as a result of their
confrontation with he who remains that
conception of the Multiverse features of
blue tree light time stream branching
off into different paths when magello
horror explains the malt Morales how the
Multiverse Works in Spider-Man across
the spider verse this familiar imagery
makes a return viewer hologram
at this point Sony has gotten a little
obsessed with making reference to
unpopular Spider-Man meme in their films
in the post-credits scene of into the
spider-verse Miguel O'Hara is introduced
to Spider-Man 2099 as he travels to the
universe of the 1967 Spider-Man animated
series recreating the meme image of two
Spider-Man pointing at each other in an
alley the meme was again referenced on
the set of no way home when the three
actors also recreated the image during a
behind the scenes costume fitting now
with the release of across the
spider-verse the meme makes its
on-screen appearance yet another time
albeits under slightly different
circumstances after learning of the
spider society's intention to let miles
father be killed by the spot miles makes
an escape from their facility as O'Hara
orders everyone to stop Spider-Man
yeah
even the casting choices and across the
spider-verse contain Easter eggs among
the varied voice casts are also two
members of The Lonely Island a sketch
Troop that gained notoriety on Saturday
Night Live for creating viral digital
Shores like Lazy Sunday and the shooting
your motokoni who previously voiced
several minor characters and into the
spider-verse appears early on as a
variant of the vulture inspired by
Leonardo da Vinci alongside Tacony Andy
Samberg also makes an appearance in the
film as Ben Reilly AKA Scarlet Spider a
moody variant who serves as a higher
member of Miguel O'Hara's spider Society
Riley a clone of Peter Parker made his
comic book debut in 1975. before he
later adopted the Scarlet Spider Persona
in the 90s during his first appearance
on the film some bug's Riley is seen in
the wave of York contemplating his
tragic backstory before later joining
O'Hara in hunting down Morales on Earth
1610. samberg's appearance in particular
may be an Easter egg to his work on
Saturday Night Live as a comedian
appeared on several occasions dressed as
Spider-Man hanging upside down one of
those times destroying the monologue of
Emma Stone in 2011 where he
unsuccessfully tried to recreate the
2002 film's iconic makeout scene with
her in front of her then boyfriend and
co-star Andrew Garfield
is British oh America's suffering record
unemployment and we outsourced
Spider-Man to England
spice is important so Miles Morales
historian into the spite of us Jay
Johnson's P2P Parker doesn't appear in
across the spider-verse until towards
the end and he's revealed to be another
member of Miguel O'Hara's spider Society
with him Parker has taken along his
infant daughter Mayday Parker who has
adopted her father's ability to climb
walls Mayday Parker is a fairly
important character in Marvel Comics
history first appearing in a whatsif
comic from 1997 when Mary Jane Watson
never loses her baby with Peter Parker
Mayday Parker is born and becomes
Spider-Girl though in that comic
meyday's Powers don't develop until
she's a teenager she later made her
official Marvel Comics debut after
positive fan responds to the what if
comic though the infant Mayday gets most
of the attention in across the
spiderverse at the variants of Mayday
also appeared throughout the spider
Society sequence albeit ones that come
from a different universe and Peter B
Parkers after a cameo appearance in the
post-credits scene of into the
spider-verse the Spider-Man from the
1967 ABC animated series makes a return
appearance and across the spider-verse
this classic version of Peter Parker
pops up to attempt to stop miles escape
from the wave of York unfortunately this
version of Spider-Man doesn't pose much
of a threat and is almost immediately
dispatched by Miles this Peter Parker
isn't even the only Spider-Man who
debuted on TV to make an appearance and
across the spiderverse the Japanese
Spider-Man from the 1978 Japanese
live-action series also shows up as part
of the spider Society accompanied by
Josh Keaton's version of Peter Parker
from The Spectacular Spider-Man and in a
blink in your missing moments the
Spider-Man from Spider-Man Unlimited can
be seen chasing miles webcape and awe if
you've been watching your Spider-Man
movies and you've probably noticed some
familiar moves from your favorite web
Slinger or web slingers as a case may be
drawing one sequence for Miles Gwen and
pavita attempt to stop the spot from
wreaking havoc in mumbarton pativa
rescues a Bus full of citizens including
his girlfriend from falling off a bridge
you might notice that the scene closely
resembles a moment in 2002 Spider-Man
where Spider-Man rescues a group of
citizens including Mary Jane Watson from
the Roosevelt Island Tramway it pops up
again in Spider-Man homecoming when
Peter saves his classmates including his
romantic interest Liz from the
Washington Monument another iconic
Spider-Man move that's referenced and
across the spider versus Tom Holland's
trying to hold a split Ferry together in
Spider-Man homecoming which is
referenced by a lone Spider-Man in the
wave of York making himself into a
bridge that a crowd of spider people try
to run across
the ending of across the spiderverse
features some familiar faces for
audience members who loved into the
spider-verse abandoned by the spider
Society Gwen Stacy realizes that Miles
has ended up in the wrong universe and
recruits a team of spider people to help
rescue him from the clutches of his
alternate self that group includes into
the spider-verse characters like Penny
Parker Peter Porker and Spider-Man Noir
as well as Peter B Parker and Mayday
however Penny Parker's Mecca's received
some upgrades since the last time
audiences saw her and into the
spider-verse I'm from New York in the
year 3145 I have a psychic link with a
spider who lives inside my father's
robot and we're best friends forever in
that film a Mac resembled an actual
spider but this time around it Bears a
closer resemblance to Penny Parker's
original Mech design from her edge of
spider-verse comic debut in turn the
comic book version of the Mecca's at
Sony Easter egg the storyline of Penny
Parker Drew lots of inspiration from
Neon Genesis Avon Galleon a Japanese
anime centered on a group of teenagers
who pilot to weaponized Mech just like
penny according to artists Shake yrt
included several characters from Neon
Genesis Evangelion as Penny's classmates
in the edge of spider-verse comic as a
tribute to their inspiration the twist
ending of across the spiderverse finds
miles mistakenly ending up in the wrong
Universe after using Miguel O'Hara's
technology to send himself home since
the spider that bits him was from Earth
42 rather than Earth 1610 miles ends up
in a version of his world where there is
no Spider-Man even worse the miles of
this world has been raised by his uncle
Aaron to become the prowler what truly
changes things for miles is when Aaron
takes him to the roof of their building
and Miles sees a graffiti tribute to his
father Jefferson Davis instead of the
tribute to Aaron in his Universe if you
are shocked by this twist you might have
been too distracted to notice a subtle
nod to the creators of Miles Morales in
this tribute spray painted in faint
green ink near Jefferson Davis's
graffiti Memorial other words Bendis and
forkelly which refer to writer Brian
Michael Bendis and illustrator Sarah
perkelly the two creators of Miles
Morales are probably used to being
referenced in this way since they also
appeared in Miles phone contacts and
into the spider-verse Bendis amperkelia
also referenced in Spider-Man homecoming
and the files for Donald Glover's Aaron
Davis with one of his criminal aliases
being Brian burkelly
foreign